has anybody ever danced on GQ I'm the
all right
bet K completely ruined this generation
by the
way cuz like now everybody just be
saying r r r you either got it or you
don't damn you said top 10 Essentials
what are you talking about it makes
sense right it's essential bro it's part
of life get facials bro I get a facial
once a month when you order your your ox
and she disrespectful you know going to
hit extra got to keep God first without
him no matter what your religion is make
sure you praying oh my God you know like
if you know you know bro now when I put
this on it's like handsome times too
don't that Bo yo with some th different
you know what I'm saying people didn't
really pay attention to my smile until I
got the grills cuz it put you to sleep
I'm telling you this right here I also
got um skin condoms
indeed y thought I was done I'm never
done I got another fridge no it's really
my central you got to have a fridge